did
you
I Victory I know this life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are on rurs we get
no value to ha Romie look what I become
I'm the
one I love it okay episode number what
Rob what number are we on today what is
it 346 346 pbd podcast today we were not
going to do a podcast but then
yesterday when we did our po we didn't
get into a lot of the current events and
we got a lot of stories to get into we
said let's do a PO today okay let's do a
pot today which is exciting we got a lot
of St stories to cover with you there's
a feud going on on Twitter over Dei I
don't know if you guys are following
this or not Mark cubin Elon Musk back
and forth here's what Dei stands for no
here's what Dei stands for then then
Elon Musk finally asks so does Dei apply
to your NBA players like you have an
Asian women short Asian
woman imagine that was fantastic and
they went back and forth which was
entertaining and then Universal
officially surpasses Disney as top
grossing studio for 2023 would you have
guessed that would have happened
Universal passes Disney but then in the
afternoon like Tom said NCAA inks an
8-year contract with ESPN worth
$920
million Nets fine for sitting players in
the innba first which is great I like
this whole thing about teams being fine
for finally yeah sitting players uh fed
official says rates could remain as high
for some time a matter of fact Goldman
Sachs says
rates will stay above 6% through 2025
not even
2024 I don't know if I agree with that
or not but we'll see what it happen and
we'll cover we'll cover that as well
Apple stock downgraded as Barclay's
warns on cooling phone demand meanwhile
Microsoft is about to pass up Apple as
the most valuable company in the world
you'll find out why
62% of small business owners earned less
money in Q4 of 2023 than they did in Q4
of 2022 let me say that one more time
two out of three small businesses in
America made less money in Q3 of Q4 of
2023 than last year 2022 pretty
interesting yeah small businesses by the
way this is not good cuz small
businesses are 49% of jobs give or take
in America so that's not good news
Blackwater founder Eric Prince predicts
China will invade Taiwan in Spring of
2024 Rob run a poll do you believe China
will invade Taiwan before the end of
this year Russia's Ukraine Hamas Israel
do you think China's going to capitalize
we'll see we'll talk about
that uh Islamic State takes
responsibility for deadly bombings in
Iran Trump and Des the santis target
Haley with only 11 days left until Iowa
sixth grader killed five others hurt in
shooting at Perry High School in Iowa I
know you got some updates there
Harvard's new course have you guys taken
this new course or no have you and Adam
taken a course been all over this new
course is the Taylor Swift course Taylor
Swift I'm telling you right now I'm only
going to go to that school I'm going to
leave this got on that course took the
udemy course yeah Epstein brother did an
interview with uh uh Tucker Carlson 27
minutes it was fantastic a lot of Intel
about different people he talked about
Al Sharpton and Bill akman got into it
and bill akman is now asking for the
entire resignation of Harvard's board
after Claudine gay stepped down which by
the way even though she stepped down you
know they're still paying her 00 Grand a
year because she's still teaching a
she's a professor she's still doing it
cuz well you know that helps out when
Barack Obama calls and says hey don't
fire her completely by the way you know
what the valuation of Twitter apparently
dropped this is according to Rolling
Stone the value of Twitter has dropped
ready 71 a half% since he bought the
company fact that's the number that's
that's an insane number discuss that why
you American cosos keep quitting in
record-breaking numbers and then just a
billion dollar doesn't cut it to live on
this exclusive Island in Florida and
then uh Ray EPS you know that that guy
that apparently was an inside job on doj
declined to prosecute him now they want
him sent to prison W I wonder why weird
and then we got a couple videos to show
you guys one of the greatest campaign
videos of all time the great Joe Biden
campaign video If you really want to
start off your day being motivated we
will start off with that video just to
get you fired up meanwhile quick
recognition Adam's the first person on
Manet to cross 600 mans great job just
last night I did movie is that from just
last night I did 20 mans and I bought 8
man talking to other users on man if you
are not using the app man relationship
convers guy asked me a question
yesterday about marriage another guy
asked me a question about a feud he's
having with his partner another one
asked me a question about you know a a
relative that's working in his company
as a salesperson that got caught doing
something how do I handle this then you
have raising kids then you got comedy
with you then you got business stuff
with Tom and getting your kids in big
schools then with Adam I don't honestly
I don't know what they talk to Adam
about but they talk about partying
ladies girls money I'm going to pay for
one pad just to see what the hell he's
about honestly it's mostly like hey man
I'm in between jobs I'm thinking about
doing this I'm thinking about this I
thought it'd be more like dating
relationships that's kind of where it
started a lot of personal finance other
direction people have paid to talk to
you for a reason yeah so I I'm sure
you're giving him great feedback cuz he
got a lot of five stars how go sexy
congratulations let's get right into it
let's get right into it let's get right
into it do you want to start off with
Elon musk's Twitter deal let's start off
with that Elon musk's X is worth
71.5% less than when he bought Twitter
says Fidelity so Fidelity is not like a
you know a regular uh company it's a
multi- multi-billion dollar company with
a lot of money under
management here we go Elon musk's X
formerly known as Twitter has lost 71
and a half% of its value since he bought
it according to Fidelity One of company
shareholders one of the company's
shareholders this decline comes just
over a year after musk acquired Twitter
for $44 billion and renamed it to x with
Fidelity estimating its current value at
around $ 122.5 billion significantly low
than musk's own October estimation of
$19 billion musk's ownership of X has uh
been marked by controversy with hate
speech Rising on a platform after his
takeover leading to Major advertisers
like Disney Apple IBM severing ties
additionally recently failed to block a
California law acquiring social media
companies to disclose their content
moderation policy so Tom
71.5% of X has dropped why do you think
that is and do you think elon's really
worried about this number I don't think
he's worried about it I'll tell you why
Elon M's X is worth 71% less than when
he bought Twitter interesting enough
Jeff bezos's x is also worth 71% less
cuz she's been giving away his fortune
oh
I'm was a comedian singer so um but no
Elon mus saw this coming he came and he
bought this and when he walked in there
and what was he carrying the first day
he walked into Twitter uh sink the
kitchen sink I'm here to change let that
sink in right so there we go so he kind
of knew this would happen but you have
to remember this is a public stock
stocks go up and down as soon as and by
the way Disney apple and IBM and the
some of the things they're boycotting in
the back drop in America is Dei kind of
getting you know get its fingers slammed
in the door a little bit which means
some of these advertisers are going to
be coming back and soon as they come
back as here but what is happening right
now is Elon Musk a Buy and Hold guy when
he buys things or is he a builder he's a
builder He is building functionality
we're seeing it right now we're seeing
things happen and by the way Twitter's
had outages there's a thing about outage
this week but just remember he is
currently running the current Twitter
with onethird the staff that he did
before Annie's building new
functionality in it suffering with some
things but what's going on in the b in
the background is a stronger Twitter is
emerging and as soon as the corner turns
on micr subscriptions because he was
charging people for the blue check and
he's going to be charging people for
other things and he was a destination
for things like uh a Tucker Carlson show
so there's a lot happening in the
background while the pressure is on the
stock and the advertisers are away you
know what's going to happen as soon as
the advertisers step back and some of
these other sub descriptions go all of a
sudden Elon Musk is going to make an
announcement and a quarterly report just
like he did with Tesla now we moved we
sold a lot more cars than you thought we
did remember those announcements come oh
he's got all these trouble and you know
you know full self-driving FSD has got
problems and he comes out well there may
have been problems but we we we sold
30,000 more calls than we thought
also what happens Tesla is up at 260 or
whatever it is the single most you
valuable Auto stock I don't think he
worries about this I think he's going to
make a comeback on it but more
importantly right now he's developing
and adding things to it Twitter is
getting more valuable from a technology
standpoint not less valuable so I'll
give you a little feedback Tom because I
agree with you for the most part it's
it's it's all about timing short term I
think this is a freaking disaster
imagine you buy a house for a million
dollars million dollars a year later
your house is now worth
$300,000 let that sink in for a second
sink in Tom so so anyone in the short
term would be like dude what the hell is
happening here now long term I think we
all know that he's a Visionary he's a
builder I think he's going to build this
thing back up but let's not pretend that
whatever he touches whatever he does
just automatically turns the gold I
think we're all fans of Elon I think
we're all seeing what he's doing with X
formerly known as Twitter but this is
not a good look not not a good this is
not a good look and last Point yeah
there is some preced in here so you
talked about stocks going up stocks
going down we saw happened to meta
Facebook when f Facebook changed their
name to meta tanked tanked now they're
up as high as ever but they turned it
around but their business model didn't
change and they weren't telling
advertisers to go [__] themselves so
there is some uphill battle here with
Elon I think we all like Elon Free
Speech Advocate free speech absolutist
he's absolutely trolling everybody right
now he's feuding with Mark Cuban I think
we all believe in Elon but if this was
your company if this was your house and
you were down 70% in 14 months you'd be
very very weary I'd be nervous but I do
you have to cuz I take a step back I'm
not I don't know about the money I I
know it's bad but what he's doing for us
as as Humanity that we get to see now
cuz dude if you think about it if it
wasn't for him buying X right now would
you be here this whole Epstein thing you
would have heard it maybe once on CNN
Fox would have been touching on it and
it would have been gone thank God for
him cuz bro he cares about the people
that we could talk he he loves Humanity
he wants to give us a form and Adam do
you think he really I mean he cares
about money or does he does he care
about Humanity does he care about
letting us talk and letting us have
these conversations so you know what
he's doing he's running a 501c3
nonprofit philanthropic organization God
bless you we see that like if there's
issues on the traditional social media
you know whether it's YouTube whether
it's Instagram what have you okay let's
go to x he won't censor that but but if
you're trying to make money which a
company is supposed to be doing you know
they're not doing it well sash you would
know this I mean X is not a dividend
stocks this isn't Hilton IBM AT&T the
classic dividend stocks that used to pay
mom and dad to private companies not
mean public anymore
right right you know and but the day he
comes back out the day he goes and the
day this this all comes back home to
roost you know is he happy about the
value no is the advertisers leaving kind
of a pain in the ass did he want to get
on stage and says hey Bob Iger and
Disney go go off you know no he didn't
want to do that but you know what my
point is don't dance on his grave and
this thing I don't think people
understand what is coming back you know
look and what I keep saying is look at
Tesla Look at Full self-driving look at
the Innovation look at battery use look
at all the things that you're seeing in
Tesla that everybody else is doing look
Tesla is making contracts with everybody
else to be the gas station for the EVS
they sell so yeah real real dumb guy he
is he's selling razor blades everybody
else is making razors and so I I don't
think he's happy about this but don't
dance on his grave baby I tell you I
really don't think he gives a [__]
that's what I really don't think he
gives a [__] he sitting there saying you
guys worry about the stuff tell the
story tell all the stuff that you guys
want to talk about um when you when you
trust yourself to know that you're going
to deliver and you've done it over and
over and over again your level of
confidence is so high that when people
second guess you it's almost like
because here's how life works I I had a
meeting with you and I had this
conversation together in Aspen one the
mornings right and I showed it to him I
said look here's how life Works in life
the first time you cast a vision that
you're going to win at the highest level
okay and you're on your peers what
happens like like Saul is here is
upstairs right sa a friend of mine that
you know him and I used to sit at
Denny's and we would talk me him and
another guy and we would say like hey
one day and one day one day We're
Dreaming dreaming dreaming how do you
know the other person is real how do you
know the other person is not full of
[__] how do you not know that a lot of
people are full of [__] right okay then
you fast forward then you talk a bigger
dream then your friends are kind of like
yeah so when are you going to do this
now huh look at this idiot he said
where's your car where's your money and
then people start working with you and
then you sell it to them then they quit
on you you're not going to pull it off
you're not smart enough you're not this
you're not you never why would I believe
you're capable of doing this and who's
right by the way all of those guys are
right cuz you have them proven to the
marketplace then it happens then those
guys call and some of them lie to your
face and they say what we always knew
you were going to make it yeah and those
guys call and they say what man I'm not
going to lie to you bro I didn't think
we were going to make it [__] I'm not I
was actually a hater and you know the
fact that he did it good for you but now
you go on your next run and those people
now say what well I know he did it
before but dude there's no way in the
world world he's going to do it again
okay now you have to go sell the newer
people in your life and some of the
people that were in your past life
they're like no I believe this guy so
for example David saxs get a call for
Elon guess what David says n this guy's
going to do it hey what do you need Elon
boom and then so the people that are
close to you your level of reputation
the marketplace they going to come
through goes Higher and Higher and
Higher and Higher and
Higher but every single time whether you
like it or not the second guessing
Community is going to show up and
they're going to keep second guessing
you and that's what elon's going through
right now and guess what Elon the
difference for him today he doesn't have
to prove that he's smart he doesn't have
to prove to the world that he's Rich he
doesn't have to prove to the world that
he's a cool cat he doesn't have to prove
to the world that he's a great troll he
just has to ask himself the question no
one in the world knows more about what
it is to build a trillion dollar company
again than this guy the question is does
he want to do it and knowing how he is
guess what the answer is of course he is
okay of course he is but he's going to
go through his
experience of whatever's going to happen
here with Twitter and by the way this
leads me to Dei I just going to ask you
one quick question cuz of this he
purchased uh Twitter X for $44 billion
billion how much was his own money that
he put down how much did he raise he he
did a little bit of both he got a little
bit of debt it was a little bit of his
own money he sold a little bit of uh
Tesla stock if I'm not mistaken but yeah
he he did a little bit of everything so
let's say he put in 10 to 20% right
let's say he put in 4 billion 8 billion
whatever yeah that other 35 Plus billion
mhm that money those investors what are
they thinking right now they're like
this is a horrible investment they have
to be thinking by the way you nobody
told you to get in nobody told you to
get in don't get in why' you get in who
hit Arc you know whatever Kathy Wood
whatever her name is who told you to get
in nobody told you to get in it's said
gamble you talking about you shouldn't
have gotten it if you don't want this
kind of risk it's your risk tolerance so
Fidelity it's great you're reporting you
can [__] and whne all you want and kind
of put it on him that it's his fault
it's not Fidelity because a lot of these
guys have to write these bad articles
about Elon to say that it's elon's fault
it's not Fidelity's fault it's elon's
fault it's not you know AR it's elon's
fault it's not this I get it but you
made the recommendation to the client
and we said yes so one at any Line's fa
two you made the recommendation three
the investor the money person that put
it in you said
yes you should have known from the
beginning what the risk was going to be
going into Twitter Twitter was never
going to be something you were going to
buy we knew day one it was overpriced M
he knew it we knew it everybody knew it
he said he was overpriced by 50% within
a couple months after buying it he
called it a nonprofit yeah with the Bots
and everything that was going on yeah so
he he he was never like over Elon never
oversold Twitter at all from day one
never he always undersold he always told
you it's worth less he always told you
don't do it he's the guys that telling
you you sure you want to go going on
this with me you sure you that's his way
and by the way that's my style of doing
it if you don't want to do it don't do
it hey you want to be married to me it's
going to be hard he you want to be in
business with me it's going to be hard
you want to work with a startup it's
going to be hard he came from that
approach which is the right approach so
nobody else can [__] and whine about it
that went in cuz he told you from day
one it wasn't worth what he bought and
he and by the way they're not going to
whine I just looked up real quick he
brought in $7.1 billion from the joke is
it was elon's friends and family and one
of them was Larry Ellison who put a
billion yeah who put a billion dollars
in and he says he's going to turn it
around it's just a matter when and that
was so and Ellison is not playing with
this kid's College money you know these
are people that's an example of what Pat
just said that is a long-term player
that says I believe not Ellison though
Ellison is different because Ellison is
musk Ellison is musk's Mentor so if
there's any there is the profile of guys
like Ellison they're not everybody
Ellison profile of investors make up a
very small percentage the majority of
other people went and said oh my God I'm
about to 10x my money I'm about to 3x my
money no you're not no you're the people
that should have never gone in with him
because he's not that guy the Ellison
guy he knows who he's banking on he
knows who Elam musk is he knows what
he's doing it's like I'm giving you this
much money I don't want this money
returned for another 5 10 years I just
going to say about time horiz and they
knew that this was a 10-e investment not
everybody and not everybody thought that
this was a 5 10 year investment at the
minimum no no what saying is not
everybody knew and went in with that
mindset a lot of people just went in
with the mindset of you know oh my God
we're losing money oh my God what if
this and oh my god let's make the return
on this that those people made the
mistake those people made the mistake
anyways all right so let's go to this
next story which is Mark cubin and uh
Elon Elon and the what page is that on
Rob if you can help me direct towards it
let's see what that is page eight okay
here we go page eight oh billionaire
Mark Cuban pushes back
against Elon Musk again this time it's
over Dei okay so let's see uh what
happened here and um here we go the
latest to Wayne on the debate is Shark
Tank host Mark Cuban who defend the Dei
initiatives into corporate world in a
post on X on Wednesday Cubano was also
responding to comments made by Elon Musk
whom he previously publicly criticized
who equated Dei with racism in a post on
X earlier that day in Cuban's view Dei
helps companies find Talent they
wouldn't discover otherwise without it
people of various races ethnicities and
orientations will be regularly excluded
from hiring
consideration according to Cuban good
businesses look where others don't to
find the employees that will put your
business in the best possible position
to succeed so companies that forgo Dei
practices only stand to lose the loss of
Dei phobic companies is my gain Cuban
wrote Muscat earlier written on X that
di is just another word for racism shame
on anyone else who uses it by the way go
to Twitter and if you can put this
exchange Rob I don't know if you have it
is that the one okay uh let me help you
out give you my okay first of all
discrimination on the basis of race
which di does is literally the
definition of racism so show more so by
the way on the bot yeah show more show
more right there okay let's read what
Mark cubin writes he says let me help
you out and give you my thoughts on Dei
help you out like Yan needs help but
let's help him out diversity good
businesses look others don't to find the
employees that will put your business in
the best possible position to succeed
you may not agree but I take it as a
given that there are people of various
races ethnicities orientation Etc that
are regularly excluded from hiring
consideration by extending our hiring
search to include them we can find
people that are more qualified the loss
of the phobic companies is my gain 1 a
we live in a country that with very
diverse demographic in this area in this
era where Trust of business can be hard
to come by people tend to connect more
easily to people who are like them
having a Workforce that is diverse and
representative of your stakeholders is
good for business now go all the way to
the bottom and see what Elon retweets
back go a little bit more okay right
there okay let's continue with equity
and then Elon responds back treating
people equally does not mean treating
them the same I made the mistake for a
lot of years thinking ad did Equity is a
core principle of business put your
employees in a position to succeed
recognize their difference is but that's
not what Equity they're talking about
Mark this is a different Equity you're
talking about go to the next one number
three uh inclusion one of my favorite
saying is great employees reduce the
stress of those around them great
companies create environments that
reduce unnecessary stress of their
employees I'm not talking hit a quota or
getting the product out the door stress
which in turn increases productivity
this is what inclusion is all about
making all employees no matter who they
are or how they see themselves feel
comfortable in their environment and
able to do their jobs again it's not
easy go a little lower
he continues uh here one of the
lessons in their minds okay so what's
the conclusion if you don't think
there's a need for dii and doesn't
create a competitive Advantage for your
company just look at exp poost replies
quotas below these are the same people
that work for you or your co-workers
everyone is entitled to their own POV
but these are same feelings even if they
are not said out loud or heard out loud
Ashley stclair responds and says thei is
seen as a core competency in most
companies is just a huge expense yes and
at any time you make something like di
requirement it will turn into checklist
and eventually lucrative industry you
give a pretty liberal breakdown of Dei
from a definition standpoint but seem to
gloss over what Dei and sister program
such as Al affirmative action has become
an actuality which is ironically rather
discriminatory equity and equality are
also wrongly conflated here the reality
of the is destroying Merit ocracy to
hire based on race and gender for extra
social credit points this is wrong and
will only breed F uh further division in
the country Rob go back and go back to
the one that Elon just responds back
quickly go back right there I think it's
the first one go one more right there go
a little lower no no you got to go back
one more you had it
earlier uh cools so when should we
expect to see a short white asian woman
on the maps that is so funny Tom you
hear us what do he think think about
this de explanation from Mark Cuban I I
think Mark Cuban is is trying to uh play
to the choir and he is trying to kind of
keep one foot not getting yelled at on
Dei and the other foot oh I'm an
independent entrepreneur and I I think
Cuban is is also making a a Bedrock of
his argument there is it that people of
color or other people aren't going to be
considered because of their race so what
he's saying is you know companies are
racist and they're not even looking at
these people anyway that's not true
that's absolutely not true companies are
taking great strides to find the
absolute best people you know it's one
of the interesting things that that I
read about in in terms of HR is is the
whole um take the name off take the name
and and the zip code and the City off of
your resumés and just and don't name so
you don't know if it's male or female or
you're interpreting it's male and female
by the by the the name at the top Chris
could be Chris Chris you know Terry
Terry so you take that off the top and
you just look where's this person been
what have they done that's interesting
let's interview them that's interesting
let's talk to their references and let's
do it on Merit you know hiring there's a
lot of effort being done out there to
hire in a fair way because companies
want great people look at the situations
we've had here we're trying to find
great people in key places we don't care
what you look like we want to find great
people and Cubans out there saying well
you know um Dei is my gain you're l loes
my gain what are you talking about if
I've got better people than you do I
don't care what they look like I'm going
to beat you Mark and his premise is oh
well you know these people wouldn't be
found anyway because of the way they
look that's playing to the inflammatory
mob of all hiring is racist and so I
think Mark's trying to keep one foot on
both sides of it he's always like that
it's it's very interesting when Mark
because Mark plays politics slippery
slope like trying to be an independent
but you know you know he's a full-blown
liberal he's yeah but but at the same
time economically he knows this [__]
doesn't work 100% but why is he so why
is he spewing it why is he talking about
so so so Cat Williams said something
very interesting on his podcast with
Shay sh sh with Shannon sharp and he
says you know a lot of these guys in the
community they will tell you we you you
we back each other up you know when
you're in Hollywood you do this and you
do that and you do this when you're in
that Community everybody in that
Community is defending each other
whether the idea is shitty or just
defend it just back it up they're not
going to be uh uh not defending one it
just seems like that's what he's doing
whether whether it is his intention or
not whether it's you know what he
believes in or not it's just it's the
position he keeps taking the well let me
tell you why di let me tell you why ESG
we have to stop doing this and we have
to stop doing that no no di failed ESG
failed these ideas failed period and
just give it to him give it to him and
say it was a bad idea is what it was let
me uh break this down I love what he
said about all right so instead of
getting the best player for your
basketball team just hire a what do you
say a short Asian woman to play for team
let's break this down and just simplify
this message arguably the best player in
the basketball right now is Luca dones
okay other other than Nola jic MVP jool
embiid you might say yis whatever it is
just to understand Dei you don't sign
Luca okay MVP candidate averages 30 a
game 10 assists because to fil fulfill
your Dei quarter you ah we can't have
Luca we got to have sunu over here who's
54 Asian woman because that fills our
quota no you're trying to win basketball
games that's the goal of an NBA owner
that's the goal of a GM that's the goal
of a head coach win games win
championships not check off boxes so is
the 54 Asian woman that uh Elon alludes
to help them win Champion championships
of course not so to be clear Dei in its
most simplistic forms is Reverse Racism
it is anti- straight white men it is the
patriarchy and that's what they're
looking to do here so at the end of the
day the the you know what happened with
the S&P uh you know there's the S&P 500
everybody talks about but there's
actually the S&P 100 here's a little
food for thought what percentage of
America is White America America 30% 60%
Vinnie 60% I was just TR to be you know
my black friends 14% Asians that they're
looking to hire for the Mavs 5% my
Hispanic Latino friends
192% S&P 100 do you want to know how uh
they've they've they've infused their
way Dei into the S&P 100 top 100
companies you know what percentage of
white people that top S&P has hired this
past year 2021 2022 with as far as it
goes back 6% 6% so just let let that
sink in for a second 60% of America is
white the S&P 100 the top companies in
the country in the world only hired 6%
of its workers white people so that just
shows they're not solving for a
meritocracy they're not solving who's
the best in the business they're just do
doing the Dei check check in the box
look at claudian gay president of
Harvard that's a prime example by the
way 23% of who they hired was black many
of those companies and they're scared
100% 22% were Asian 40% Hispanic so
we're looking for the best people for
the job we all saw what United um
Airlines tried to do they said moving
forward 50% of who we're hiring is going
to be women 50% be men yeah we got a
problem here buddy 90% of pilot are men
so now you're putting people's lives in
Jeopardy just to check off a female box
yeah the hell with the hell with you
think I give a [__] it's men woman
[__] whatever get me on my flight safe
to where I'm going period I want to win
a championship I want my company to make
money I want to arrive in my city safe
don't care who it is best person for the
job I just don't have any respect like
when it comes like a mark cuat like you
said they're flipflop they're lukewarm
their foot is here like it's like I
don't have any respect for somebody that
doesn't take their stance and stick with
it he's he's obviously suffering from
Trump the ranger syndrome which is one
of them but I don't like I don't like
this flip-floppy making everybody happy
he's a man stand up stand your ground
and say what you really by the way let
me just send you this article here Rob
can you please please pull up this
article and show it to the world do you
know the man who is screaming di di
di thei let's do thei is it do you know
according to Guardian please pull this
up and show it to the world do you know
what team is the whitest team in the NBA
the whitest pull up the whitest team in
the NBA according to the
guardian what the hell are you talking
about dii yeah the argument is over you
have the whitest team in the NBA yep the
Dallas Mavericks are consistently white
in a black
game that's also a reason they Haven won
a championship since Dirk nitzky in 2001
but by the way here's what I will
Champion has an asteris Dirk was white
here's here's what I here's what I will
tell you guess what the mths he he puts
the right he's got a good team yeah I
actually like what he's doing with the
team my argument isn't his team I do
agree Luc is a top three guy in the NBA
he's eventually going to be the the best
guy in the NBA I think Giannis is right
now number one cuz Giannis is won and he
hasn't proven himself yet so this guy's
a top guy but that's another but but
yeah Joker's also top three in my eyes I
just put if I have a choice between
jannis and Joker I'm taking jannis but
Mark you realize how much your argument
loses credibility when your team is the
whitest team so let's go read it on the
bottom let's go read it on the bottom
here to what the stats is so the NBA was
74.2% black 16.9% white it was very
Mavs okay often kept the dreams of
mediocre white guys alive yet one
franchise has kept the dream of mediocre
white this is just a pot calling the K
of the last 21 math Seasons there were
three or more white players on the
12-man active roster in more than half
of those 15 Seasons there were at least
four white players not to mention at
least two starting white players the
Mavericks in the literal sense do not
like these uh like the rest of the
league it's tempting to put this down to
racism or at least unconscious bias on
the part of the Mavericks owner oh [__]
Mark Cuban but if anything the opposite
is true although the Mavericks have talk
although the Mavericks have a dubious
history of toxic workplace culture when
it comes on to female employees Cuban
has thrown his support to Black lives
matter and D we by the way don't just
skip over that last point the women
thing yes they had major issues
internally with the women and sexual uh
allegations going on there for years
systemically within the M that goes to
your point though he's he's full of [__]
he's flipflop by the way I have a friend
Pat you guys will respect this he's a
comedian I'll Rob his name is Adam
Hunter you don't have to look it up he
said I think in basketball there
shouldn't be any overtime at all when
the regular time is done whichever team
has the most white people they win there
you go why even have overtime let's not
cross over this do you remember the
incredible storm and and and Mark Cuban
should be thanking his personal God that
there was Dan Snyder in Washington at
the Redskins now the commanders because
that was a horrible toxic culture for
women who he had the special calendar
made you know with the their own um
cheerleaders and it was really
inappropriate and all the stuff that
went on there at that same time that
created the cloud in front of the fact
that the NBA was going through the same
thing with the Dallas Mavericks and
women and what was going on and so Mark
should thank Dan Snyder for making a
bigger problem for women that he hid
behind while it was being fixed in
Dallas but but you know what this does
though you know what this does here's
what happens when you have a story like
this when you're going out there and
criticizing and then all of a sudden
you're like yeah yeah but yeah but yeah
you know what happens if Elon Musk finds
out okay go tack by the way if you're
watching this podcast do a short clip of
this put it on Twitter tag Elon Musk and
say Elon did you know that Dallas
Mavericks are the whitest team in the
NBA do you know what Elon would do the
troll chop of this anyways uh so just
keep in mind one thing about the
Mavericks um or Mark cubin and you'll
appreciate this we always talk about
establishment anti-establishment
disruptor there was no bigger disruptor
in the NBA than Mark Cuban when he
entered the league no bigger D this guy
got fined every single game he's yelling
at half million
this guy was a disruptor but here's what
happens eventually you bend eventually
you end up on Shark Tank eventually you
get owned by NBC eventually you're part
of CNBC eventually China eventually the
disruptor becomes part of the
establishment now he's establishment and
he's basically calling out the
disruptors like the Elon mus well guess
what this article of Guardian is
officially live so good luck go go try
to hide this Guardian article noest team
in the NBA right Adam it's barbarians to
bureaucrats at the end of the day you
end up on the back end and you're a
bureaucrat bang bang bang bang
bang although Couples Retreat bang Cuban
gets another you said we going to go
back and bang bang bang bang Tom you
threw me off here let's go to the next
let's go to the next story here next
story we got is uh 62% of Vinnie I'm
coming to this one with you 62% of small
business owners earned Less in Q4 2023
than Q4 2022 this is a Zero Hedge story
let me say it again 62% of small
business owners made less money in Q4
2023 than they did in 2024 a December
small business revenue report by
alignable reveals that 62% of small
business owners experienc a decline of
Revenue during Q4 2023 compared to last
quarter this figure is notably higher
than 52% who had previously anticipated
a disappointing Ford quarter the primary
concern among small business owners has
shifted to ramping up Revenue overtaking
worries related to inflation
approximately 37% of those surveyed now
engage in side jobs to wow that is
insane small business owners 37% are now
engaging in side job Uber to supplement
their income while an additional 56%
take on side gigs to cover mounting
expenses leaving only 7% satisfied with
the income generated solely from their
business damn small business owners
continue to Grapple with the
challenges of high interest rates
affecting 52% of them moreover 41% of
small business owner renters reported
being unable to pay their rent in full
and on time in December while 51% faced
rent increases Tom this is not this is
these are real numbers with small
business owners facing these guys are
running companies and they're getting
jobs on the side so I I I just called
the White House and they said the the
econom is fine and they hung up on me
that okay then let's skip the story and
go through no so here's what's going on
we all talked about this and this and we
said that the fourth quarter was
probably not going to be as good as a
third quarter because Americans dipped
into helocs they ran their credit cards
up to a trillion dollars and they said
oh the consumer was resilient resilient
well guess what we're hearing we're
hearing that Q4 was not the barn burner
that Q3 was and now small business
people are hurting we said Main Street
is going to hurt this is the economy
coming home to roost and this is uh
consumer spending down in fourth quarter
and this is the small businesses are not
worried about the inflation now they're
worried about raising their revenue and
they had a decline in Revenue in Q4 23
versus 22 what decline consumer spending
and so this is exactly what we talked
about that that that underneath
the headlines for wow look at the S&P
500 Oh you mean the S&P 7 The
Magnificent 7 and Nvidia chips that
freaking drove that engine all year you
mean that underneath it the economy is
not in great shape and interest rates
are high and going to be here for a
while and this just shows that um below
the surface people are still having a
tough time despite the headlines that by
the way yeah go ahead go ahead Adam
because I was say this is egregious I I
just want to use a big word I just want
to take a second to just say how much I
appreciate small business owners uh you
have no idea what it's like to own a
small business why do I say that I don't
own a small business I'm an entrepreneur
I'm not an entrepreneur there's a
difference I've always been the number
two guy or the top sales guy I'm never
the guy putting down the capital taking
on the risk okay and to do that and we
and listen all the guys we meet here at
Value tainment everyone at the Vault
everyone at pbd Consulting at bet David
consult insulting you have no idea how
much respect I have for these guys they
lay it all in the line they bust their
ass they work their tail off to create
jobs in America what percentage of jobs
created in America are uh created by
small business I think it's like 50%
right it's even higher than that Tom we
can pull that up I think there's 33
million small businesses America that
employ well over 60 million Americans
these are job creators these are
Hustlers they are entrepreneurs they
stay up at night they're working their
freaking tail off they trying to do
something there it is 33 million of
small businesses in America turns out I
know what I'm talking about these guys
are what makes America tick I'm not
talking about the S&P 100 the S&P 500
these guys are not small businesses
these guys all have what how many
employees is it considered to be a large
business 5,000 employees whatever the
number is I'm talking about the guys
with three employees the guys with 10
employees the guys with 80 employees the
the solopreneur just trying to create a
a job and get it off the ground I have
so much respect for these people and you
you know what percentage of small
businesses fail what is it 75% within
the first 5 years these guys are
Hustlers and they're doing what they got
to do to feed their family to to to make
their legacy to make their impact on the
world just want to give a shout out to
the small business owners and the
entrepreneurs have they ever did I mean
Co set this off for them to start
failing horribly right Tom like
especially and and and overwhelming
percent of it I think like 40% of the
failures were restaurants which was the
mom and pop restaurant who got shut down
and didn't have the didn't they not like
Cheesecake Factory oh I'm a chain I'm
just going to do delivery I'm going do
all this they didn't have the ability to
do that one of the biggest ways I
support Adam 100% what he just said I
Echo that that feeling and one of the
best ways you can support small business
in your community find the small
restaurants that are that are usually
and by the way you're usually going to
find great food and you're going to find
great food from different places all
over the world where they're operating
in in your town and that's one way you
can support small businesses is is find
the small restaurant that's doing it I
love in Miami and I will plug at
Espanola I love going down that little
Street Espanola Way baby yep I love that
little street they're all independent
businesses what Tom saying espanol is
the whitest ever espol I love espol
espol you know what Tom made me think
about every time Tom comes over Tom
talks to Melva and he he talks to Mela
in Spanish and I swear every time
Melville comes to me afterward saying
why does the sceno try to talk
Spanish holda
freak her
out I'm like NOA just he's he's he's
making an effort doing I I freaked her
out I tried to say good morning
apparently I said there's a demon in the
pool the cheese is old and mold Sorry by
the way for those of you guys that are
watching a podcast and you're seeing the
glitching going on this is not us we're
on a T1 Line This Is YouTube it happen
happened yesterday it happened today
we've never experienced this before and
I know just dropped out right now what I
ask you to do is I'm going to put the
link of my tweet okay what I just sent
on Twitter to YouTube If you could be
kind enough just go tag YouTube and ask
what is going on and I think they
responded back to us yesterday um let me
do this again and uh uh let me see what
I got here did did the Tweet show up
there on the comment section or no rob
you put it there okay fantastic on the
pbd podcast if you can go and just
retweet that and comment on YouTube as
well I think enough people asking a
question of YouTube that will get their
attention this has never happened so
we're not sitting here saying this is
you know here's what's going On's going
all I'm saying to you it's the first
time this has happened last two days and
it's happening again and what upsets me
is the fact that you keep watching it
and then all of a sudden 50 ads come up
so we just turn off the ads Rob just did
so you don't have to worry about the ads
but we're listening to you we're paying
attention to what you're doing and I
know you guys got busy lives and you got
a lot of other things doing for those
you guys are coming back and staying
with us we appreciate you we do this
with you we do this for you and we enjoy
it we we like doing this we sometimes
are going to have technology issues and
glitches that happens in life you can't
get discouraged you got to stay strong
whether it's the adversary not wanting a
message to be heard uh we're going to do
our part to get that message over to you
and we we trust eventually YouTube
technology team is going to figure this
thing out and we'll get past this and uh
we'll get ahead of it so having said
that if you can do that we will kindly
appreciate it appreciate you guys let's
go to to the next story all right so
next and by the way the the best thing
sometimes for you guys that are in the
states if you want to make sure you
always get our material text to Word
podcast to 31034 11132 text a Word
podcast to
31034 11132 anytime that something
happens with like yesterday's podcast
that Community will get a text with a
new link to be able to watch the content
so again to make sure you protect the
longterm text the word podcast to 31034
11132 and guess guess what future looks
bright D does future looks bright all
right so let's go to the next story
chart of the day mortgage rates will
stay above 6% through
2025 Goldman Sachs says we officially
lost 3,000 loan officers that got off
the podcast yeah they just got off
they're like screw you bye but but by
the way screw Goldman Sachs who that
said this this is not our story but
let's read we like Goldman Sachs Goldman
Sachs predicts that 30-year mortgage
rates will remain above 6% through 2025
with a projected rate of 6.3 by the end
of 2023 and six in 2025 this revised
forecast reflects expectations of fed
interest rate cuts and a narrowing
spread between mortgage rates and
treasury yields last week the average
30-year mortgage rate was 6.62 showing a
decline from its recent peak of 7.79 in
October this trend indicates some
improvement in housing affordability but
not a complete reversal of the rate
increases observed from 2022 to 2023
lower mortgage rates are expected to
stabilize the mortgage back Securities
market and lead to increase mortgage
origination projected to reach $2
trillion in 2025 up from one and a half
in 2023 Tom so here's what's happening
and so let's get give us all a little
quick lesson here uh Rob can you pull up
for us really quick the um tene treasury
rate as of today should be 3.99 4 .05 or
something like that right now sitting on
it yeah there it is 4.04 four so the 10e
treasury is 4% this is what the
mortgages are tied to now with the
normal spread is this is the Spread
spread is the bank profit so Banks buy
money at this rate and add 1.5% to it
that is the traditional spread
historically so this should be
1.5 so this should be 5.5% now now let's
go to the 30-year 30-year this morning
should
be 7875 no no no 6875 to 7125 something
like
that the 30-year 30-year fixed mortgage
you had it before yeah same way the
spread that's on the 30-year fixed
mortgage right now is almost three
points why are banks Tom how does he
show that CU I've not seen it 30y year
mortgage rates he had before what's a
30-year fixed mortgage today 30-year
fixed mortgage is what 6.8% something
like that correct all right zoom in run
seven yeah seven seven a quarter 7.2 so
so normally the spread is 10year
treasury plus a point and a half so
mortgages should be 5.5 to
5.75 why are they
7.23 the banks are putting 3% spread on
it right now because of what they're
calling prepayment rate risk what's
prepayment risk refinancing so the banks
are keeping the mortgages right now at
7.23
7.5 because they believe in less than
two years the consumer is going to
refinance the mortgage and they're
trying to build in profit to it
historically the 10-year treasury plus
1.5 was your 30-year fixed mortgage rate
so basically what the banks are saying
now America you're going to be paying
higher interest rates for a while cuz
the rates aren't going to come down
enough and I think as soon as they come
down you guys are just going to run back
in and you're going to refinance it so
the banks usually don't have a
profitable mortgage for about two years
because what happens is they pay
commissions out they have their costs
that go into putting that that Mortgage
in in motion Mak sense it's their
business cost and if someone refis it
two years before it happens so what are
they doing they're building in what's
called prepayment spread and that's
what's going on right now so Morgan is
Morgan Stanley is right these and and
when interest rates come down next year
some of that spread's going to come out
because that part will not be refinance
now the rates are down and now what they
believe the future will be 5 and a half
to six and a quarter that's only 3/4 of
a point a point so your prepayment risk
is lower so basically interest rates
higher for longer means we should all As
Americans expect mortgages to be higher
for longer and that
six rate Cuts next year of a quarter
point is only a point and a half so you
do think it's going to stay above six
next year and six next year I'm with I'm
with Morgan Stanley with Goldman Sachs
with gold yeah excuse me excuse me yeah
okay go ahead Tom give your answer go
ahead no no no yeah I I'm I'm with the
banks and I believe that that's exactly
what's going to happen that we're still
going to see six and a quarter mortgages
at the election got it um Tom you're
super smart but sometimes you're too
smart because Vinnie
did you understand what he just said
yeah no you didn't no I
didn't so let me simplify this for the
Vinnies out there because I I got what
Tom was saying and it was a great
breakdown but sometimes you not smart in
the face bro you know you know say
stupid let me explain something to you
yeah so you got to look at anything
you're buying is it cheap or is it
expensive am I getting a good deal or a
bad deal right now you're not getting a
good deal bro M Rob I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to uh have put Rob to
work pull up historical mortgage rates
okay
um here's what's happening we're having
to supply and demand issue so while
you're pulling that up right now
everything is based on the FED fund rate
you ever heard that term fed fund rate
basically how much Banks charge other
Banks to basically borrow money and and
and all that the um so that current rate
is 5 a half per. what that was was four
years ago was like 2% Pat what was that
number few years that's weird okay so
now but that's what the banks charge
other Banks historical averages thank
you but now there's something called the
prime rate the prime rate is what
basically the US the people what we got
to pay so it's usually a three-point
spread with that as Tom was basically
alluded to that spread so the prime rate
is about 8 and a half per. so they get
there's a buffer the banks aren't going
to charge what they charge the the the
average person so if you look at
mortgage rates Rob can you break down
what these numbers say my highs aren't
what they used to be in the 70s was 7.3%
in the 80s it was almost 133% bro in the
90s it went down to what is that nine 9%
2000s 8 8% 2010's as cheap as it's ever
been until the 2020 showed up 3 and a
half% so we've been super spoiled for
the last 20 years super super super
spoiled so everyone you knows bought a
house in the last 20 years dude they're
getting 3% rates 4% rates 5% rates so
now when they Sky rck it up to 8 and
half% people are like this is [__]
expensive it's like yeah if you look at
that the history of this it's actually
pretty common it's actually way worse so
now it's like when everyone kind of has
Co hangover and they're like inflation's
at 8% it's it's actually a three and a
half% bro you're just still in that
given that Co hangover so right now when
they're saying that these mortgage rates
are going to basically stay at what per
P six 6 three over six yeah two years
historically that's not bad I tell you I
hope they do I'm telling you I hope they
do because there there's a there's a
part where um we we we've been not
disciplined fake success I keep talking
about fake success and you kind of
highlighted it from a different
standpoint as well we we it would be
very very good for America to keep this
thing above 6% it' be very good huh why
because it when it's cheaper and it's
lower you're you're just financing [__]
for nothing and you're getting it for
nothing and you're making irresponsible
by the way the lower it goes the more
money I make like think about it they
the more
they lower the rates my house is worth
more the lower the rate it is man not
the higher the rate it is so [__] lower
the rate I don't I don't care if it
lowers the rates it's not good for the
economy all it's going to do is increase
the rich getting rich and the poor
getting poor Y what a rate at 6% does is
kind of keeps it here because a house
that you know a guy's asking for $1
million this is not a million dollar
house bro this is an $770,000 yeah it is
but because the rates are so low you
don't have a choice you got to pay
million dollars for it but if it keep
set him 6% above next two years that
Mill could potentially go a little bit
lower all I'm saying is if these guys
start lowering the rates crazy in 2024
2025 again go for it yeah go ahead do it
I'm not affected by it Middle America
will get destroyed you think that's a p
would that be like a good way for them
to look good for like their presidential
run but then mid class is gone hor it's
horrible if they do that it's horri
horrible if they do that for Middle
America fantastic for me but don't you
but I think that's isn't that the
Elite's goal is to get rid of the middle
class you're rich or watch like what do
you think I want you think I want you to
buy a house right now of course in
general of I want you to I want to come
to your house 100% I want I want to come
to a guy's house I want to go to my guys
and pick up a place and all this other
stuff they're calling me saying what do
you think what do you think what do you
think I'm like dude you know I don't
know you know I don't know about right
now I just think right now they're
destroying Middle America
lowering the rates to zero Believe It or
Not destroyed Middle America I'm telling
you destroyed Middle America I want you
to unpack that a little bit if you lower
rates doesn't that make buying a house
more accessible for the average person
why does that destroy the average person
no no no all it does is it lower people
don't buy a house based on dollar a
month people buy a house based on what
mortgage payment can afford to buy yeah
the monthly that's it no one buys on a
price of a house or a car they buy like
right now guy goes to the dealership how
many people who buy a car say to follow
I'm here to buy my budget is a $35,000
car nobody says that people go to
dealership and they say what my budget
is $500 to $600 a month yeah exactly
give me show me what I can get yeah
nobody says $35,000 car except for
people that have cash right yep and
somebody who goes to buys a house they
don't say my budget is a million to
million $2 home they go to the realtor
and say what my budget is $4,000 a month
pni everything include everything $4,000
a month okay then we have to deal with a
$600,000 house there you go okay so so
zero they say yeah you can buy a million
dollar home and I'm going to sell it for
million dollar cuz you're thinking I'll
pay a million dollars because my budget
is what $44,000 a month because the
rates are so low so this is terrible
idea I hope they stay to the six I hope
Goldman Sachs wrote this article for the
FED to be like oh [__] if Goldman says
it we better stay here so it's kind of
like a you know how Stephen A Smith
sometimes says stuff that maybe you know
I sit there and I wonder are you saying
it or did the Lakers leak this to you to
talk because you got the biggest mic so
the NBA can listen to you and maybe Adam
I wonder if some of that kind of thing
so whenever whenever I see Stephen A or
some of these main voice he's number one
he's not number two whenever I hear
something I'm like oh okay huh who told
you you know what I'm saying Insider
information I wonder I wonder because
Stephen A is on the inside of a lot of
things is who he is we like ourselves
from Stephen A okay all right so there
you go next sixth grade
killed five others hurt in shooting at
Perry High School in Iowa Authority by
the way did we do the ad for gold we
didn't even do that right is it I'm
assuming it's too late right now at this
point to do okay we'll skip it today
okay sixth grader killed five others
hurt in shooting at per High School in
Iowa uh uh tragic when you see this but
unfortunately many many of these keep
happening and and there seems to be a
trend with it we'll see if there is a
trend gunman 17 years old Dylan Butler
open opens fire at Perry High School in
Iowa killing a sixth grader and wounding
four other high school students and an
administrator Iowa division of criminal
investigation assistant director Mitch
uh States it's not yet clear why the
sixth grader was in the building at the
time of the shooting police discover and
improvise explosive device device in the
school Iowa State Fire Marshal and
Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
render it safe according to uh the the
director Mitch mortv Butler armed with a
shotgun and a handgun made social media
posts around the time of the shooting
the incident occurs on the first day
back from winter break calls for
stricter gun laws emerg but Iowa does
not require permit to purchase a handgun
or carry a firearm in public as of July
2021 which wouldn't have made a
difference anyways this guy was a 17 no
good and and the Iowa when's the Iowa
caucus uh n days eight days it's it's
it's coming up but you know and
everybody's fixed on the Jeffrey Epstein
thing and I and I trust me I'm I'm in
the same boat cuz I want to find all
this information but that the that
person that that killed the first of all
look at this guy he's in the lgbtq
community by the way when the cop showed
up like a coward he shot and killed
himself but you know trans he was
transgender fluid and then let's let's
look at this pattern bro remember the
the Colorado Spring choer a while back
Anderson Lee Aldrich non-binary remember
the Nashville shooter the Audrey hail uh
transgender Aberdine Maryland shooter
snoi Mosley transgender Denver school
shooter Alec you guys are you guys
catching on to the trend Alec mckin
trans uh in regard to the Nashville
shooter Aubrey Hill the manifesto
remember the manifesto that they
wouldn't release it it's almost like
they were hiding it from us any other
school shooter that leaves a Manifesto
we get to see it because they're they're
I think they're trying to hide it
because The Narrative of this white
people and white supremacy BS is
happening when when are we going to stop
and be like okay listen it's not like a
crazy epidemic right now but it seems
like a trend where these people I don't
know if they're mentally unstable but
the LGB Rob what's the what's the LGBT I
don't want to I don't want to mess it up
because you're going to offend people
Rob currently
lgbtq I a2s plus what does that stand
for they also threw a piie sign in their
mou yeah what does that stand for
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
Andor questioning interex asexual and
two spirit and the plus sign represents
the many ways people choose to self and
that's the point I I know you're a smart
guy you don't understand anything Rob
just said no I thought he was describing
the chemical uh formula for salt yeah
but my point being and I know what
people are going to say oh it's not the
lesbians and gay no no you guys are it's
a community because they lump everybody
in with which they shouldn't which they
I 100% agree but it's it's the teas and
the and the weird ones but it's like bro
they're radicalizing the youth this is
becoming an extreme movement they're
going in there and they're shooting and
then the media is protecting by the way
it's not known that this person was I
had to dig deep to find out who this
person is and it's like bro when are we
going to address the fact that there's a
mental health issue happening Tom you're
hitting it so perfectly the issue is Tom
that that that weird but go ahead you
you are you are hitting the nail on the
head on this topic sorry about that and
what you have is people that have that
are mentally ill are hurt people and
hurt people hurt people these are
depression and and suicidal thoughts and
then people act out and this is a
horrifying way that they act out and
we're we're going to make it about the
guns and we're going to make it about
white people we're going to make it
about everything else than saying what
is going on with the folks and what is
up with the the Mental Health crisis in
America and you can go right back to RFK
who made a comment at the town hall
meeting that said decades ago when we
closed the mental health instit
institutions in America that were
providing care and and and solution of
where to put these people and where to
take them so that they weren't hurting
others around them and we shut those
down and all these people are on the
street and then these things are
untreated and we're saying that there's
someone else is causing you to be what
you are rather than getting these people
assistance and keeping them safe for
they don't hurt other people I'm out end
of story we this is to me like you know
how you get worked up about you know the
sound of freedom and stuff like that
like how and how upsetting that is to
you this this is my top of my list most
upsetting thing like I I'm like tearing
up right now imagine okay you're you're
a parent mhm it's the first day of
school yeah you're getting your kid
ready to go to school you're excited
like when I was a kid I used to like
literally sleep in the clothes that I
was going to wear then I was so excited
to go to school and then my mom would be
like hey you got to take them off you
get a shower for school that's another
another story but you you're a parent
you know and you're getting your kid
ready for the first day of school and
you get a call from the school yeah
there's been a shooting at the school oh
my God and your kid just died because
some [__] mentally ill weak person
showed up 17 years old and he wanted to
murder little kids in this case it was a
what sixth grader sixth grader and a
bunch of other My ne's in fifth grade
sixth grade like he's coming in sixth
grade this upcoming year it to me it's
the most sad cuz when we were growing up
what' we have to worry about maybe
getting the [__] kicked out of You by
some bullies we didn't have to worry
about someone coming in and shooting up
the school MH and to me that's the
saddest thing and this goes back to this
this is reminiscent of what happened at
Sandy Hook right under you know
President Obama Sandy Hook Connecticut
when he was a president came out there
and made a big speech this is obviously
why our buddy Alex Jones owes a billion
dollars in fines we all know what he
said what he did and as much as I
actually really like Alex Jones he was
dead wrong on that um but to me it's the
saddest freaking thing you have these
little kids that are going to school
trying to just be educated have fun play
Recess learn do your thing make friends
Y and they get killed for just being a
kid you know they say that there's uh
three types of genders or three types of
uh gender ideology there's men women and
just the mentally ill and you
highlighted what's going on with those
people is a lot of times they're just
mentally ill and they're weak you know
how you're not a strong person if you
get a gun and you show up and you kill
kids you're weak you're not tough you're
weak anyone can do it the the Sandy Cook
shooter was a skinny scrawny nothing
person of a kid mentally ill weak and he
took it out on kindergarteners dozens of
them to me this is the saddest epidemic
that's going on in America today I can't
even imagine what it would be like to
have a kid and lose them because they're
just trying to go to elementary school
it's disheartening it's saddening and
unfortunately here's the sad reality of
it it's another story in the news day
move on nobody even KN nobody even knew
about it but but Adam and wouldn't you
be even matter if you knew like there
the government isn't even addressing the
main problem which is the mental side of
it all they want to do is say it's guns
guns guns at them because at the end of
the day they don't want us to have guns
because guess what if it wasn't for the
Second Amendment Tom guess what all of
in here would be vaccinated all of us
would have our rights I'm telling you
right now that's why every other country
hates us is because we have the Second
Amendment God thank God for our founding
fathers bro the First Amendment and the
Second Amendment cuz they would trample
all over us when they they notice how
they don't give they don't give a [__]
about the kids they're just like oh take
the gun it's the gun no no can we take a
step back this person was obviously
mentally ill they're pretending to be
nonbinary they're posting [__] online
nobody's saying anything because you
know what no no no you're transphobic
you're you're fob that and you talked
about this the other day phobic phobic
enough with that [__] cuz they're
it's going to keep on happening people
are going to still by the way at the end
of the day get rid of the guns that
person will come in with a truck and
drive right through the the the crossing
the street they're going to die if they
listen to me if I want to kill people
Adam I don't need my gun trust me I'll
make it happen and these sick people
could do it we need to start worrying
about the mental health so because guess
what Adam if I started pretending that I
was I was a dragon and I came in here
like wouldn't you guys say something
would don't you report would you be like
Pat you as the CEO you be like yo we got
a v needs help let's address the help
you know what I mean cuz then guess what
the next day I come and throw fire on
everybody I'm like oh [__] how why why
would he have done that because you
didn't address my my sanity my insanity
but we're just they're protecting that
community and it's backfiring yeah one
one more thing you're right if you're
mentally ill and you want to take it out
on people and you like Tom said I like
what you said would you say hurt people
hurtt people it's so true you're going
to find a way unfortunately a gun is
actually the most convenient way it's
the great equalizer as Pat has mentioned
in the past so whether it's a car
whether it's a knife whether it's a
machete you're going to find a freaking
way it just so happens that the gun is
the easiest way to do it and I just
don't understand why these schools are
gunfree zones every school should have a
police officer a security detail
whatever it isan front and back of the
school you ain't coming in this school
unless you go through this big door with
a security and why don't we have it at
them they don't give a [__] at the end
of the day they don't care all these
other people are armed with people with
guns everywhere you go people are
security from LeBron to all these people
have security but when it comes to the
kids we're like no I don't get it I just
don't because they don't give a [__]
these politicians I I I I want to go
deeper than these politicians have kids
or they have grandkids it does not give
you any political expediency to
basically have dead kids at your
doorstep it does nothing for for your
approval ratings Congress approval
ratings are alltime low so there needs
to be a deeper situation here than just
they don't give a [__] I assume they do
I don't know I just I I wouldn't give it
to I wouldn't give them that because
they why why why is everybody including
the media hiding when it's a transgender
shooter the manifesto so there's
something to be there that should be the
first thing I want to see is what the
hell was going on in here but they hide
it cuz it doesn't fit the white guy uh
with Biden's uh extreme no it's [__]
crazy people we're crazy people and they
don't care at them cuz there is no
explanation why aren't they guarded and
we see what's going on America anxiety
is at at all time high depressions at at
all time high people anet you don't
think I'm anxious right yeah but you're
just angry yeah cuz I'm but in a good
kind of angry you're the kind of guy
that I want on my team with a gun yeah
so let's go let's go to the to the next
story obviously super tragic what's
going on and if it doesn't fit their
narrative they don't want to talk about
it but I'm going to tell you what's
going to happen it will backfire it just
will because the story is going to catch
up and it's going to be personal to them
just like a Robert dairo who cannot
stand Trump to save his life a
documentary was coming out at a uh
Festival movie festival and it was the
vax documentary it was called vax I
believed or something like that and he
talked about his son he never talks
about it his oldest son is autistic MH
and Robert Den was not a fan of vaccines
he's a fullblown liberal hates Trump to
the highest level but guess what when it
comes down to vaccine they're on the
same page really yeah I mean I don't
know if you've seen this document in the
interview what he does and how he was
silenced and he's like I don't really
want to talk about it but this and this
is something everybody else watch I
didn't see it you did not know yeah so
So eventually enough of people are going
to flip and they're going to say this
doesn't make sense Common Sense
eventually prevails but before it does
it destroys a lot of people's lives
Common Sense eventually prevails before
it does it destroys a lot of people's
lives and it's happening right now let's
go to the next story
so um Dei with Harvard Alum Bill Amman
calls for resignation of board members
who supported Claudine gay here we go so
supported Claudine gay um where is this
at Bill acman Harvard Al and Co of
persing square Capital Management
insists that the corporation board
should not remain in their seats
protected by the unusual Governor
structure which enabled them to obtain
their seats he calls for the resignation
of board members who supported former
president Claud and gay and board chair
Penny pritsker Amman identifies uh
Harvard diversity equity and inclusion
policies are as a root cause of the
institutions problem Dei stating the Dei
movement is an important contributor to
our growing divisiveness he expresses
concern about the impact of these
policies on Harvard and the broader
educational system now Al Sharpton
targets bacman over criticism of
school's ex-presidents Dei he says uh
civil rights activist group National
Action Network plans to pick it outside
billionaire Harvard's graduate billman's
New York office on Thursday in protest
of influential lumps pressure campaign
to oust exh Harvard president Claud and
gay and his criticism of diversity
equity and inclusion president Gay's
resignation is about more than a person
or single incident Sharon said this is
an attack on every black women in this
country who's put a crack in the glass
ceiling it's an assault on the health
strength and future of diversity equity
and inclusion at a time when corporate
America's trying to back out of billions
of dollars in commitments most of all
this was the result of Bill amman's
Relentless campaign against claing
against claing gay not because of her
leadership or credentials but because he
felt she was a DI hire and by the way
more stuff came up about her
plagiarizing and Harvard's still going
to pay her 9 $900,000
by far there is something we have to
consider here that is actually very uh
uh serious thing for us to consider we
have to know that anytime you work with
somebody as successful as her you she
she has AB absolute keys to success and
there's three keys to success that I
think everybody can pick up from claudin
gab Rob if you can show to everybody I
think it's important for people to see
this the three key to success by cling
G control copy and paste that is so
funny that is somebody just sent me that
Meme right there it's funny as hell I I
want to say Trump just posted this or
not but uh yeah so when you have a story
like this and you're going back and
forth and then Sharpton comes in and
it's a black thing it's a race thing
again I mean you're you're going back to
exactly why Dei was a shitty idea in the
first place go ahead Tom you go first go
ahead Tom you know what very interesting
I'm just going to go to one thing we'll
go to Adam it's like the longer Al
Sharpton speaks it's kind of funny if
you've watched him on cable when he gets
going and they don't interrupt him he
usually accidentally discloses the real
truth and he did it here at a time when
Corporate America is trying to back out
a billions of dollars in commitments
commitments to what it's the Dei
Shakedown that's what he's talking about
so he's upset because the money train is
about to stop and the Dei the the the
the Investments by Corporate America
that went to foundations that had
nothing to do with Dei he's talking
about the Shakedown and the longer he
speaks eventually he speaks the truth he
says at a time when Corporate America is
trying to back out a billions of dollars
in commitments commitments to what Al
what exactly yeah ad you you guys know
that apparently Barack Obama who he went
to Harvard correct yeah he called and
lobbied like he's like don't let her go
keep her on who gives a [__] like keep
her in the position and then like leaves
and then 900,000 like she's teaching a
class still is that what it is she's
getting $900,000 a year to be a
professor who what do you what is she
going to teach well remember so is um so
is Penn Penn the president resigned and
she went back to being a professor so
they they take one step but then they
also kind of circle the wagons a little
bit so Tom I want you to use what you
always talk about with uh when there's
issues and there's problems um and you
talk about what's going Upstream versus
what's going Downstream break that down
then I'm going to make my point oh oh
Upstream problems versus Downstream
problems Downstream you find a polluted
lake and the Liberals want to build A1
trillion filter to put in the lake and
they want all of the people that are
using the lake that have any money
whatsoever they want to tax them to
death to pay for it m whereas Upstream
somebody goes upstream and says well
where's the stream that's putting all
this crap in in the lake coming from and
they go upstream and they find out do
you know the camps Ides are dump dumping
Ash and everything in here and there's
also a uh you know a pesticide Factory
here and there's this farmer that's got
all this runoff you know if we reroute
all this stuff and take care of that
properly then that's going to be a happy
little stream filling up the lake with
clear water maybe we'll just fix that
and it's onet of the cost but it's twice
the effort cuz it's so easy to stand up
and say we did A1 trillion filter and we
need all those other people to pay taxes
to pay for it right so essentially it's
addressing the root of the problem the
the the the cause of the problem not
sort of the symptom of the problem
Downstream but the lake is that kind of
a fair assessment so Claudine is not the
problem she is just the symptom she's
basically the the downstream effect of
the problems that have basically
infected Harvard and just the university
system for decades okay so she is her
head's on The Chopping Block it's been
chopped off what have you but she's not
the problem she's the Martyr she's the
Figure Head said she's the latest victim
of this woke Dei ideology but you know
they came out with the
rankings of the uh Free Speech amongst
college right talked about this
yesterday Harvard this Bastion of
intellect the the the Oxford of the
United States the best place to go to
school in the history of America do you
know what ranking was Harvard was in
free speech dead last meaning meaning
meaning that is the the the the worst
free speech in University in America
okay so the reason that I say that she
is not the problem she's the symptom
she's only been the president since July
1st 2023 she's been there like 6 months
yeah just showed up bro quick these
problems are not because of her she was
hired because of the problems because of
the Dei because of the ESG because of
the wokeness that's how she got the job
plagiarism or not what do you see there
Rob just a chart that shows exactly what
you're saying uh rank number 248 in the
free spe rankings Harvard univ these
problems that are going on on Harvard
with the Gaza Brigade and the you know
the trans stuff dude they're they've
been lingering for decades and then she
shows up and they're like okay black
lady shaved head yeah we're going to get
her out of here but she's not the
problem she's a deep deep symptom of the
problem where it's no longer a merit Ry
no where it's no longer a free speech
campus it's all right put her in
position she checks that box she's black
she's a woman boom we need that but Adam
you think she got kicked out because of
her you know black woman or because the
fact that they couldn't answer the
question of why they were allowing this
anti-israel anti- it could have been any
race in my eye I said this the first
time yeah any time someone gives you an
open-ended question are you Pro or
against genocide and you say I don't
comp just take the I'm against genocide
whether it's Jews whether it's blacks
whether it's Mexicans whether it's
Asians whether it's Christians whether
it's Catholics whether it's Muslims
whatever it is be on the opposite side
of pro genocide how freaking hard is
that to do so when someone goes well you
know depends on the context they go what
context the
actual of genocide that's when you
should speak up what are we talking
about here so that's made people's
headlights go
yeah what's going on around here and
then when you're going to start losing
funding they have the biggest war chest
of any college what the the biggest uh
what's it called P endowment endowment
of any school ever what is it like $50
billion what's the number whatever it is
ridiculous okay so meaning like the
philanthropist the donors the big time
donors are like yeah I I'll I'll put up
a wing in the business school and name
it after my family I'll donate to the
sports program whatever it is and all of
a sudden I mean listen you know you go
to Harvard you make money right Bill
Aman Obama Mark Zuckerberg went to Har
didn't graduate these guys donate
they're the philanthropist they're
donors they're Mega donors if the mega
donor starts saying yeah I'm not getting
you cutting you a hundred million check
this year people are going to take
notice Money Talks follow the money so
at the end of the day she's not the
problem she's a deep deep symptom of the
problem so her head was on The Chopping
Block as sort of like a you know uh sure
will make you happy and you all appease
what going on here but she's a symptom
of the problem this is not her fault
unfortunately she's the current
president she had to go there you go k
she still gets paid $900,000 so let's
just call it a million a year that's
banana great comp plan work for a
company for five months get paid
$900,000 a year how awesome of a reti
guys they're hiring Harvard's hiring all
you have to do be is you have to be a
very unique set of De requirement you
can plagiarize Your Way to the Top If
want obviously right yeah a great
strategy by the way you know what
happens if a kid plagiarizes at Harvard
what happens he gets kicked out you know
what happens if you plagiarize as the
dean the person running the entire the
president you know what happens you're
Gonzo you get to be asked to go retire
and we still pay you 900 Grand how
awesome is that sign me up great compl
sign me up and you have an ex president
calling are you saying leave them there
consequence of plagiarism vary by
institution and severity common
consequences include a lower grade
automatically failing the course
academic suspension or probation or even
expulsion can plagiarism be accidental
how many of those kids at Harvard are
using chat GPT to write their new report
that's all over how many kids shoot the
president yeah what I'm saying get the
kids not only am I a client I'm the
president yeah so so yeah it's it's a
it's Air Club for Men by meanwhile I
because it matters a lot Harvard
introduced a new Taylor Swift course so
popular it needs more teachers okay it's
a Taylor Swift
course let me read it to you and with
her new play standards V is coming teach
Harvard University Taylor Swift course
titled Taylor S Taylor Swift and her
world has become incredibly popular with
over 300 students enroll nearly 300
students enrolling Professor Stephanie
Bird who leads the course sought
additional teaching assistant due to the
overwhelming interest the class explores
various aspects of Taylor Swift music
and impact including her songwriting
things of adolesence adulthood
appropriation and queer sub subtext in
seriously yes it also delves into the
influence of Taylor Swift's music on the
economy referred to as Swift onomics
Taylor Swift's immense influence on fan
culture and the fan economy is
significant focus on the course with her
eras toward generating over $5 billion
in revenue and fans spending up to
$20,000 a ticket Adam yeah we covered
this yester in the sast by the way
Vinnie crush it yesterday in the sast
tune in Thursdays 4 P p.m. anyway uh you
know the argument has been made is
college even worth it it's College of a
scam okay if there's if you need more
evidence that it costs more and you're
getting less value than ever look no
further than your kids enrolling in
Taylor Swift courses okay and you know
one of the girls made an argument
yesterday it's like well then maybe they
this is how they learn to become this is
how they learn to become like a singer
or like a songwriter I go no you learn
to become a singer by singing yeah you
don't learn to become a basketball
player by watching Michael Jordan videos
Tom what are you doing Tom smoking a
bong doing got Tom smoking that bong
yeah um you don't learn to become a
basketball Bear by watching Michael
Jordan videos you get out there and you
shoot some hoops so this whole situation
with Taylor said by the way it's not
just Harvard again we talked about the
problems are systemic this is just one
of the situations it's also at Cal
Berkeley it's University of Texas in
Austin my FL Gator buddies out there
they're doing it up there it's not just
Harvard here's other nor Eastern's doing
it South Carolina's doing it Austin P is
teaching case courses so at this point
this argument has been made for years
now is college worth it is college worth
it is college worth it we all know that
it back in the day 60% of college
students were men and 40% were women it
has completely flipped now it's
basically 2/3 women one3 men so they're
saying you don't need a college go
anymore it's it's overrated it's
whatever
what's what's more ingratiating yourself
to young women 20 years old than saying
hey if you go to college you can go to a
Taylor Swift course sign me up it might
come with a free Swifty ticket to her
next concert it just shows how woke
college has gotten Pat has highed this a
million times thanks for teaching me
this Pat there's what 13 conservative 13
liberal teachers for every one
conservative the number is growing and
here's more evidence that you can just
go to college pay 50 Grand a year 100
Grand a year to learn about Taylor Swift
unbelievable meanwhile in business law
over in the business law class maybe
there could be a class on how to do a
bad contract remember her first contract
just like handcuffed the first part of
her career she had to remake her whole
1989 album The tlor vers maybe there's
something in there like this is a case
study on how she screwed up her career
made a bad contract maybe they could put
something like that in there but you
know that you mentioned Cal Berkeley
yeah Cal Berkeley is is doing a home
defense course it's a home defense
course it's taught by Paul Pelosi
Intruder no stop it Intruder front door
step one remove pants step two poor
Scotch so it's it's like how to protect
yourself
Hammer but you know
what bring poor Paul
Pelosi made $100 million on stocks Adam
you you would think you would think
Harvard with all the stuff that's going
on when this this type of thing comes up
they go like this hey guys we got enough
[__] going on let's keep the Taylor
Swift course thing let's let that
marinate for here what else what more do
you need to know not to send your kids
to Harvard town what would you do if one
of your daughters Brooke was like Hey
listen dad i' signed up for a course of
Taylor Swift what would you do uh well
we're going to have discussions because
I have the I have I'm like Congress at
my house I have the power of the budget
yeah and so if I see I happen to be I
write checks and I can see what the
invoice says and what the courses are
there so you know the the the cap goes
on the pen and we have a conversation
yeah I got you he's saying you're going
to shake them off shake them off sh good
one catch I'll give you that good one
Adam Pat you want to weigh in on this
he's still in shot yeah he he can't
believe the entire time I'm trying to
get register for the next
class oh they do it online it's I like
I'm sure there's a waiting list for that
line I'm talking to customer service
right now see
well she just got fired by the way there
is a chat gbt on on using all the proper
words to not trigger customer service at
Harvard and that's kind of why it's
taking me a long time to use all the
right proper work well she's going to be
a billionaire if she's not one already
so well we'll see what she no no she's
definitely already there if you're
wondering if she's a billionaire I think
she's already made it oh she's there and
if she's not she'll be there next week
you know that by the way Taylor Swift
she just broke Elvis Presley's record
for the most consecutive weeks of being
number one on the billboard 200 yeah 68
weeks okay yeah she's worth 1.1 billion
so that happened this year yeah she
broke Elvis's record where she has a
long way to go to beat the uh Beatles
The Beatles which was um I think like 38
weeks or something like that by the time
she reaches this she'll be what she'll
be in her 60s or 138 weeks no she's got
one more year and a exactly yeah here we
go all right next Black Water founder uh
Eric Prince predicts China will invade
Taiwan in Spring of 2024 4 he predicts
China will attempt to invade Taiwan in
Springer of 2024 stating I'd be
surprised if they don't try something
under the Biden administration because
for them it has to feel like the door is
wide open wow for them to do whatever
they want to do Prince emphasized that
the weather window for potential
Invasion opens around May or June adding
if they're going to take Taiwan by force
I would predict that they're going to do
something this spring he also criticized
NATO saying Trump was right to complain
about NATO not paying their their share
and highlighting a need for Europe to
increase its industrial base for defense
supplies warning they need to crank up
that industrial base otherwise they're
going to find there's not the supply
they need when they want it when they
need it Tom do you think China will
invade Taiwan in 2024 well he's talking
about a weather window and what a
weather window is is when you know the
the ocean down there is more calmer so
you could have ground invasions it's
easier to get your ships around so he's
saying that there's like a weather
window and if you know your history
D-Day they had to wait for cloud cover
and fog to clear and so there's always
weather windows that are in there so
he's pointing out hey Biden's not doing
anything about it China has a weather
window here and perhaps the rest of the
world will be distracted and he's saying
this is a window where you know China
might do something uh and do whatever
they want to do and I think I think he
has a point I think he's out there like
an outlier on this but I think he has a
point the world is distracted there's so
many things going on we've got we're
we're righteously distracted about
Israel and Gaza conflict we're
righteously distracted about a complete
Interruption to global Shipping that's
gone on with the houthis and the and the
normal you know Suz Canal shipping the
the amount of fuel that's being by the
way inflation is going to be up simply
because of the Gaza conflict because the
shipping container ships are going all
the way around uh South Africa I saw a
so there's more so there's more cost to
shipping there and if you don't think
that's like a quarter point inflation
you're not paying attention it's more
gas to get stuff from A to B that people
are going to be buying and so again I
think Eric PR has a point uh will it
happen right
then I I don't know or or is he just
trying Pat to put it out there and to
make sure that the new cycle grabs it
and that government is paying ATT I
don't know why he would do that what
would be the motive of doing something
like that for him I know what his
business model is I know how he makes
money I know what he's doing but there's
a part of it that you know I have I have
a a bipolar opinion on this here's what
my thoughts are on this
one I believe um on on one end China or
whoever else it is is sitting there
saying okay uh what is Biden up to
anyways like when when did even say
anything like think about it if there's
one thing about Biden you don't even
know what the guy is up to right now
he's on 30 what 37% of his pres his
vacation weird so we don't know what
he's up to sometimes that's a good thing
sometimes it's a bad thing like you
don't even know if the guy is around
okay MH so if these guys want to
capitalize right now is the time to do
it because if x sits there and says okay
if we don't do it now and Trump gets
elected they're definitely not going to
be able to do it under Trump so that
means the next time they're going to be
able to invade Taiwan is going to be
what time 2029 let's just say right 2029
is if a certain person is elected they
ain't Crossing that straight right
that's that's what I'm saying yeah and
and that certain person is is Trump if
Trump gets elected till 2029 on the
other side there's a part of me that
also is sitting there thinking that a X
or China wants a trump to be president
because because there there's a there's
a part of it where at least when you got
a guy that you can talk to and
communicate you can at least know where
they're at and get [__] done if you're
not communicating with a Biden you can't
get nothing done okay like for example
when I'm doing business deals and I can
get a I would much rather get a hold of
an [__] than have a guy I'm
negotiating with that I can never get a
hold of the sweetheart I don't know if
that makes sense so when you're
negotiating with the guy I'm like okay I
already know that guy's an [__] but
guess what he picks up the call okay but
the other guy freaking he acts like he's
a sweetheart I never trust him nothing
comes out of his mouth I believe he's
Shifty he's dodgy he's always getting
others to talk to me he doesn't want to
talk to me himself I can't do a deal
with you I don't want to talk to you
perfect example I'll give you out of a
movie go to the movie Air okay air is
about what Michael Jordan the shoe deal
all that stuff Nike who's the [__] in
the movie David Faulk he's the agent the
agent right when you talk to him how
does he talk to you you're an idiot
you're this you're that piece of [__] he
talks to you like that but guess what
Sunny Vicario knew if you got on the
phone with David Faulk David Faulk was
driven by what results so David Faulk is
the guy he had to close to get the
family to want to meet with him because
he knew David Faulk picks up the call
Deal makers don't care if the other deal
maker is an [__] they just care if he
picks up the damn call and if I'm a G I
don't like I don't believe Biden's
picking up the call what do you think
the communication right now with world
leaders or with Biden honestly think
about it what do you think world leaders
say say you are Putin say you are Trump
say you are Kim say you are I don't
Maduro take anybody take any world
leader right now what do you think is
the level of accessibility to Biden
today I I was Zero there there are no
conversations last time they had the G7
conference he's standing out there and
even mcon came back out and said well uh
we understand what the United States
stands for but there is no discussion of
what any discussions were zero zero do
you think I was just going to say he's
not communicating let's has picked Putin
there's absolutely no way he's having a
conversation with him go ahead sorry but
didn't and Biden and she just meet like
a month ago yeah there's a difference to
just meet mean the photo op San
Francisco you pick up to do a deal right
I'm asking a question if you think they
are then great what do you think the
level of accessibility with Trump was
meaning and here's how I gauge access
when I talk to my sales leaders one of
the biggest mistakes sales leaders make
is they don't call their clients back
and they don't call their sales guys
back quickly so for like oh I'm so busy
[__] you're not busy call your guy
back he called you why are you taking
three days to give back to your client
call him back he's your best sales guy
give him a call right so I'm just so
busy I got so [__] no you don't A A
great sales leader is always accessible
to his best sales people a terrible
sales leader is always acting like
they're busy and they never get back to
people right what do you think it's a
basic question by by the way Rob can you
can you run
a and and if you're listening to this
just post the question if if you're the
guy most likely we're even talking to
ourselves knowing what's going on with
YouTube today but if you are able to
listen to this okay so so I want you to
think about this here how long let's run
a data data your X you're Putin you're
zalinski you're whoever you're a world
leader top 10 top 20 World Eragon put
the most influential world leaders all
right two case
studies you say Mary get a hold of the
president I need to speak with Mr
President Biden or Trump from the moment
that statement is made to getting on the
phone how long do you think until you
get a hold of trump how long do you
think until you get a hold of Biden wow
just you understand the question I'm
asking right I want you to think about
this Tom what do you think is from the
moment a world leader asks their Chief
of Staff I want to get a hold of the
leader of the Free World in US case
study Trump Biden how long does it take
to get a hold of I think Trump under
five minutes I think Biden who there's
no God knows what they're going to do I
think I think somebody else is going to
be on that phone call what do you think
the number is I'm with that I think the
G7 you know the G7 economic players I
think it's like within two hours
whatever he's doing they're going to
find a buffer between it and he's on the
phone he's on the phone you know what I
mean like if if Trump was here doing a
speech he's doing this and then boom I
think soon as he has a buffer in the
schedule he's on that phone okay give me
timeline within two hours I think G7
calls Trump austral hour what do you
think Biden is Biden honestly Biden to
get to get Biden on there it's probably
about an hour and a half hi this is
Hunter routing number and account number
please no but what do you think it is
though on a serious note like jokes
aside Tom what do you think it is Biden
I I don't think you can get a hold of
him same week and I think it's going to
be a policy walkon and like Secretary of
State okay so I think Biden is a day or
two I think Trump is a couple hours now
here's the thing in the world of getting
[__] done okay
were you going to give a number or you
don't have I agree with you I think you
know Trump's the dealmaker the art of
the deal he's going to pick up the phone
he might even just call your ass that's
I going to say but that's what I'm
saying to you so so but but in the world
of negotiation and getting deals done in
startup time I always say this a minute
is an hour an hour is a day a day is a
week a week is a month a month is a
quarter a quarter is a year you lose a
courter you lose the year okay but when
you're dealing with diplomacy and world
of Affairs a freaking minute is like
what do you like let's go we got to get
on a call right now it could be a war it
could be 10,000 people dying it could be
a a guy pressing a button you don't want
to press it could be a you know all
these other things that could be taking
place so to me I I uh I think there's a
part of the whole China Taiwan thing
that I think Trump uh X wants a trump
type because at least he gets to win or
lose based on how good of a negot
negotiator G is I think X wants to
negotiate with somebody and I don't
think he negotiate with with with I'm
give you one thing um give it so we're
talking about us and China right here
we're talking about Biden whether it's
Trump whether China attacks but
obviously there's a third party involved
who's the third
party Taiwan yeah you know it turns out
they have a say in this matter Pat you
highlighted something very interesting
yesterday you said what percentage of
the world is holding elections in 2024
it was a bunch of them 40 40 40 plus 3.2
billion possible voters uh 44 trillion
of the world economy pretty impressive
you know what you know who's on that
list Taiwan yes they are do you know
when their election is being held next
week oh wow how about that how about
that catch me outside in Taiwan so their
election is January 13th 2024 by the
time this video comes out we're one week
away MH okay we're one week away this is
they have a three-party system in in uh
Taiwan don't ask me why I know this but
I've done some research so the current
party is the is the uh the president is
the Democratic Progressive Party so they
have the progressive Wing they have the
moderate wing and they have the right
wing turns
out uh it's you know like the like super
Progressive moderate uh conservative
party here in America there you go right
there so that's the president there on
the left
liqing I'm sorry the president saing
when okay anyway I I mean you tried it's
my best it is what it is it is what it
is but the point is they have an
election and it turns out there's no
appetite amongst all three parties to do
any deal with China you know because the
whole argument like why would China
attack Taiwan why why we all think it's
about chips it's market share chips econ
market share and chips and economic
power but Taiwan was part of China at
one point right the one China policy
just as Hong Kong was right we've seen
what happened when Hong Kong basically
let China basically get their tentacles
back on them there he is Lang G okay my
guy um my guy my guy my buddy um but the
even on the right wing of the party the
the Taiwan people's party I believe
that's what it is there's no appetite to
be a part of China That's traditionally
was what their stance was that they
actually wanted to be more closely
aligned with China and it turns out that
the young people 2% of young people
under 30 in Taiwan want anything to do
with China there's zero appetite within
Taiwan to be a part of China this is
like saying Hawaii right yeah one of our
50 states we're like yeah they're part
of the Union what are you talking about
and they're like nah no we're good bro
we're doing our own thing over here in
Hawaii it's like no you're you're part
of America you're part of China Taiwan
no no we're good on that so we're going
to see what happens in a week we're
going to see what party wins we're going
to see what platform that they're
basically uh endorsing for their people
because they have a vote there obviously
what's going on in this situation now if
China needlessly attacks but there's a
situation of bruan I don't you know
China's Vision what is it China 2030 oh
God what was it pat 2025 2025 yeah one
China 2025 okay but that that that got
pushed China 2025 that got pushed back a
little bit due to co so I'm labeling it
2030 by that point either Trump or
change it for
China did it for your power is amazing
they're done well that that was their
motto preo clearly they've taken a major
hit their economy's crumbling
unemployment youth unemployment they
China's a mess right now ever Grand the
real estate situation they're sort of a
paper tiger at this point but I'm moving
into to 2030 I just made that official
but by 2030 yeah Trump nor Biden will be
the president that's a fact well yeah
okay so we'll see what happens well and
and you guys who mentioned it because
you guys are talking about Biden who
will pick up the phone so B you guys
hear there was a report that Biden when
he met uh XI he he thought it was Jackie
Chen he was like I loved you in Russia
like he's like no no that's not me and
that that the whole anyway but here's my
here's my I just [__] in that 2030
that was [__] here's my question to
you Trump wins Trump wins Trump wins
this cycle how do you think his
relationship be I'm being genuine what's
his relationship going to be with China
and she considering he was talking [__]
about trade he held them accountable
then all of a sudden covid leaked from
this lab got basically got Trump out how
do you think that relationship is going
to be he's is he going to go back to Fu
hold him accountable that's going to be
a dangerous Rel he should you're always
going to prefer a guy you can get on a
phone to negotiate with than one you
can't I'm tell Rob go back to the story
I agree but what what I'm asking you Pat
is what I think is going to happen I
think Trump's going to play ball I think
Trump's going to go out there and impose
and Challenge and you know he and his
card he knows what China's going to fear
China's going to fear an investigation
into Wuhan lab and because of that
Trump's going to get a good deal for
America because he's going to put that
to him and say listen don't make me want
to go investigate what happened with Co
cuz you know you destroyed the world I
don't make me go there and that's his
card to negotiate with that's what a
negotiator is going to do he's going to
hold down to that card Rob go back to
those charts where it said who did who
did the people of Taiwan want a
relationship with it was the blue chart
and green chart and it was like 82%
wanted relationship with you there it is
so these are the people of Taiwan they
get a vote so let's just talk about
exactly this my point we talk about the
us we'll talk about China how about the
people of Taiwan that live there exactly
have a favorable view of the United
States 68% of China 35% MH almost 2 to
one it says support closer Economic
Times with United States 85% China 52% y
support closer political ties with a
79% China 36% what's your point though
if Trump gets elected and he wants to
put the USS Enterprise on the coast of
CH of Taiwan the people are going to be
waving little flags and they're going to
want us there you know this this that's
the part why I'm bipolar with this Tom
there's a part of me that's kind of like
you know but G is going to be like why
are you getting involved with my ex why
are you getting involved with my kids
why why are you getting involv my kids
these are my kids okay stop getting
involved in our divorce stop getting
involved in our this that's kind of what
China views this because Taiwan used to
be part them so to them it's kind of
like leave this relationship alone well
they they actually sent Chen Chen kek
they exiled them to freaking Taiwan
that's how this whole thing started it
was something they didn't want it was
these it was the equivalent of it
was Hillary Clinton and the deplorables
China version you go over there you get
out of here you're not part of China
you're you're exiled over here back to
Vinnie's point about Trump's
relationship with G and China Rob if you
can check this I I I think I'm right I
could be wrong on Trump's like first day
in office he called or took a phone call
with the president of Taiwan and he
called him like yeah there is there it
is on December 2nd Donald Trump wrote on
Twitter the president of T toan called
me to wish me congratulations on winning
the presidency thank you so this is a
month into his presidency and then hours
later interesting how the US tells
Taiwan sells billions of dollars of
military commitment but I could not
accept the congratulate call CU
basically she was like yo what are you
doing bro Taiwan is part of China don't
be taking phone calls from their
president you take the phone call from
me I remember this was like big news
back in 2016 yeah big news okay yeah
it's in Wikipedia just called the call
the after the call in December 2nd okay
there it is right there Trump then what
raised down on Twitter did Rob punch in
did China ask us if I was okay devalue
their currency if I it make it hard for
our companies to compete heavily tax our
products going to their country the US
doesn't tax them or build a massive
military comp so the point is this
situation with Taiwan it was Brewing
since day one of the Trump
Administration so we'll see if there's
an act two coming up in 2024 a whole
pandemic number two doesn't come out of
there so yeah all right last story what
do we want to go with rap What story do
we want to wrap up can we do something
uplifting yeah let's do Epstein if we're
going to be
uplifting yeah let's talk about F
because hey everybody else I mean can we
get into it cuz I want to ask cuz I
wanted to ask Pat and everybody a
question about this whole situation so
you do want to go into the EP store 100%
let's go through Epstein's brother info
about Trump Clinton would end 2016 but
the Rob where's the story about Epstein
with Tucker you have the one with the
Tucker interview and the notes on that
Co FRS we've already done that we' also
Megan Kelly which she had second batch
Court Document okay here we go so uh
Jeffrey Epstein's list update second
batch of court documents unsealed this
is page eight and then yeah Megan Kelly
said something do you have that clip
about Kelly going play that CLI here
very weird what Megan Kelly just said
but uh let's go through this one here
January 5th so newly unsealed Court do
reveal claims that President Clinton and
his connection Jeffrey epon these
documents lawsuits Virginia Jay Max
would contained Miss Clinton walked into
Vanity Fair office and pressured them to
not right about Epstein a magazine
spokesperson denies the claim while Mr
Clinton spokesperson asserts he knew
nothing about Epstein's crimes the
documents are the second batch of
unsealed filings related to the law of
the first batch included names like
Trump Andrew magician David Copperfield
but does not indicate wrong indicate
wrongdoing Maxwell had been sued in 2015
by Virginia G fre for defamation but
settled in 2017 uh keeping the document
sealed until now Rob can you pull up
that clip of what Megan Kelly just said
just watch this here guys here's Megan
Kelly go for it fascinating and we're
not done with Jeffrey epsteen I can tell
you that for a fact can't tell you how I
know but I can tell you for a fact we're
going to hear a lot more about Jeffrey
EP
in the coming year uh and you may be
even hearing from him directly more on
that as I'm allowed to what is she like
yo yo can you and me and Rob just talked
about this pet before we started can you
imagine Adam out of nowhere he EP shows
up complet like protected by you know
security and everybody he's like I got a
story to tell and he has all these tapes
and everything because his brother
hiding his face I'm kind of on the fence
cuz Rob showed me earlier that he has
ties with Adam Schiff he has ties with
Maxine Waters I don't really trust the
brother he's not showing his face who
knows he's saying oh they my brother's
not because by the way the the way that
the body was handled Epstein's body they
took off his clothes they put on a gown
there there's so many mistakes besides
the cameras besides the guards it's
obviously some really really sketchy
stuff that happened with his brother P
but I I want to ask you guys a question
and a real genuine honest question cuz
they mentioned CL Clinton's the main
name bes besides Alan dtz and Stephen
Hawking which I don't even know how that
could have happened where people were
having sex with him prince Andrew and
prince Andrew but how much more do we
need to learn about Bill Clinton until
something he's held accountable for his
actions and let me just really fast he's
been accused of sexual assault wiita
brri accused him of rape in 1978 in a
hotel room where he almost ripped her
lip her lip off all right Leslie mil
accused him of sexual assault in 1980
Paula Jones uh accused him of exposing
herself in 1991 as well as sexually
harassing her Kathleen Wy accused him of
groping her without his consent and I I
don't know if you guys remember do you
guys remember what the left was shoving
down our throats no pun intended believe
all women all right that doesn't apply
if those women are accusing people on
the left moving on 1995 he was in office
Monica Lewinsky 18-month um Affair he
was hooking up with her with you know
the whole cigar story smoking it of you
know he's he's a freaking deviant and
yesterday we learned uh 50 times he was
in Epstein's document D where Epstein
told uh one of the victims told uh I'm
sorry Epstein told one of the victims
that he likes them young when it comes
to to girl uh to women so here's my
thing nobody nobody should be above the
law not the average Joe not a former
president how much more do we need to
hear from demons like this and just
information until we do something about
it right like enough is enough how many
and that's why I think it was two days
ago I told you I go there could be a
video of him Bill Clint hooking up with
an underage girl and nothing would
happen to him and people like yeah I
don't know what's going to happen to him
is anything what is it going to need to
take for him to get in trouble to
actually go to court well this is
progress I think this is a start to
what's going to happen and we're going
to see whether you know uh uh if this
will continue or not if it does great if
it doesn't it is what it is but the
reality of it is Vinnie this is progress
and and it's going to require people to
be patient you know where he was at
December 29th and where he's at till
today you he's been a Mexico really yeah
he's been in Mexico meeting with the he
they've been out of the country on
purpose you think I don't know if it's
on purpose I just know Bill Clinton spot
a smiling greeting Pastor Brian Mexico
hours before named in Jeffrey Epstein's
list uh yeah they've been out of town
they've been over there in Wan I think
it's if it's if I'm not mistaken is it
wanat or Waka let me see uh what's the
city they're in Wan yeah so they've been
they've been chilling they've been
chilling over there and gradually I can
tell you for a fact
um that there are some things coming up
uh uh and a lot of people are not going
to be what's this time that's him there
that's him in in Mexico is that the
shirt that he wore that day no that's
not the golf shirt but but this is
progress account accountability starts
with this listen if Jeffrey did you
watch Jeffrey Epstein's brother's
interview with Tucker Tu did you want
did you watch that Tom did did you watch
that what did you think about it I what
you you want to play one of the clips go
and play this clip while he's doing the
by the way just so you know this Jeffrey
Epstein doesn't like Trump Tucker
doesn't like Trump his brother he's a
liberal he's not on the right this dude
so why why why would you as the brother
of him want to come forward in this
moment to to he's not going to he's not
sticking up for him cuz he was like I
didn't see him for seven years I had no
idea about seen seven years 18 months
apart yeah he's a successful Royal
Estate guy didn't want to show his face
to Tucker I understand that but his ties
to the left you'll see it here in minute
he has he has ties to the left and it's
almost as if you know he was trying to
be like well he didn't kill himself to
kind of distract him because like with
Megan Kelly saying stuff like you might
hear from him as well there's like I
don't know what the percentage is uh Rob
we talked about this how many percentage
of Americans think that he actually
still might be alive because of all the
mistakes that were made with the body
play the
clip also play the Megan Kelly clip
after this we we we already did we
showed it you were smoking we smok
wa good high-profile inmate in the most
secure Federal facility in the country's
largest city who was somehow
murdered clearly with the knowledge of
the justice department and the Attorney
General of the United States lies about
it which he did bar and there's no
reason to do that except to cover up the
crime so what does that what does that
tell us about this oh it's a scary
thought that you could be killed in
prison by the government your brother
was dead in his cell and had been dead
for 2 hours at least 2 hours at least 2
hours somebody cut off his clothing and
redressed the Corps in hospital scrubs
in a gown yeah I have a photograph of
him uh in a hospital gown on a gurny in
a hospital where you know his arms were
put through the sleeves like you have
any other clips from well think about it
and just Adam the the cameras weren't
working the security guards uh messed up
the the body was tampered with the
brother can't find out that there's
there's so many inconsistencies and we
still know he didn't he didn't he hasn't
seen the body he didn't get to actually
see the body physically and they moved
it to the infirmary which is not
protocol you're not supposed to do it so
and then you hear all the rumors about
him with mad and uh how many times did
uh the ex prime minister of Israel go to
his house in Manhattan ah Barack a
Barack was up there how many times Rob
between 10 and 100 times okay between 10
and 100 times it's absolutely ridiculous
and pan I I understand what you're
saying with it's slowly coming out but
we've known about Bill Clinton since the
70s when women are saying he's he raped
me okay he's been a deviant this entire
time they've taken Li detective test and
they've pass which I mean CIA agents
know how to pass Li detector test the
average American doesn't do it at when
are we going to go all right everybody
let's take a time out you're a freaking
bad guy and you need to go to jail have
your day in court but dude he's a
disgusting human being he's dis Clinton
I think Clint Clinton's one of them Alan
dtz dude and why is it when you see all
these people that are accused when you
see Allan dtz when you see a John
podesta when you see a Kevin spy is it
just me or when you see these people
they all look the same they all have
that evil Vibe the Jeffrey Epstein that
photo of him in jail they look
disgusting to me and Bill Clinton is one
of them to me I don't care how good he
was for the country something
interesting to note these names are
coming out from one lawsuit there's
reportedly more than 34 different women
who have sued the Epstein estate so this
is just the claims from one of those
lawsuits imine what happens if the other
33 lawsuits and victims those
testimonies become unsealed what will
come out then tell I'll tell you one
thing about Clinton uh you know we had
the opportunity to spend some time with
him in New
York randomly at a bowling it's not like
we had a meeting I get it um you know
they call him slick willly for a reason
you're damn right so here's where I'm at
with this if there was anything anything
with underage girls hold this man
accountable 1000 whoever it is whoever
it is whatever it is hold him
accountable if it's a situation where
he's
just banging other chicks on the side
other than Hillary you got my vote buddy
I think I want to spend every night with
Hillary Clinton all right so I'm I'm
just I'm just going to go there with
that but what about what about rap what
about women saying he Gro me and raped
me addressed already been
addressed stuff the Linsky stuff I'm
specifically talking about the Epstein
stuff dude Donald Trump showed up in
2016 with the accusers at the [__]
debate have you ever seen anything like
that you like reality TV Google Trump
Clinton debate Bill Clinton who was 70
years old the time look at was 188 years
old he was about to die in there okay
I've never okay dude look at that look
look at that look come on player by way
that's not not his daughter just Google
it that is his daughter no that's not
his daughter that's Chelsea Clinton who
is the person that they say that that is
Chelsea Clinton that's that does that
look like him V by way that is Chelsea
Clinton okay get why don't you Google
who is Chelsea Clinton's father please
Rob please who Tom what's his name web
Hubble web Hubble is the
I what are we
doing what kind of nonsense are we doing
right now what type of Tom Foolery web
Hubble that's the guy
that's that's his that's that by how
about sure guys you win just a random
picture of a guy I've never heard about
you in the argument not the not not the
the girl that he's been raising since
the time she's zero and what about the
black kid from Arkansas did you see that
kid where they where they call him they
go that that that's Clinton Vinnie go do
your Unusual Suspect Clinton [__]
okay I'm not like it's not well you love
him that much I don't I'm not I'm just
saying I like to live in reality what's
what's Rob what's what's Vinnie talking
yeah who who's the who's the son of uh
the Arkansas uh Bill Clinton's uh son
Roger Stone actually wrote a freak did a
documentary about this kid and went
there who does that person look like
Danny Williams Danny Williams and that's
he he claim it yeah who is that Adam do
you have any discretion or if you just
see something it's 100% fact Adam Adam
there was a documentary Ro the whole
thing does that not look like him listen
they in the neighborhood they said that
looks like him did this whole entire
conversation before you joined pbd
podcast with freaking Dr Jordan Peterson
everyone's like of course um I wasn't I
didn't do one with I know that's what
I'm saying before you know what before
means baby UHS like who' we ask about we
oh Justin Trudeau yeah and this guy
spent two hours ripping on Justin
Trudeau he's the worst he's that I would
never in a million years and we asked
him you know there's been stories that
Fidel Castro is actually Justin
Trudeau's dad he goes I can't uh condone
this type of thing it's not uh it's not
so the point is somebody who hates
Justin trau with all his heart with all
his passion would not even do that so
believe me uh Dr Jordan Peterson hates
Justin Trudeau way more than you ha a
Clinton I can guarantee you that can
guarantee you that so use some
discretion before we [__] up I didn't
make nothing hold on hold on hold on no
I got to address this [__] comment
that you just made I'm saying from the
beginning this isn't even a fake Bill
Clinton no no Bill Clinton how much more
do you need to find out Adam how much
more do you they need to find out about
Bill Clinton to be like the guys H how
much more why do you wake up every
morning thinking about who Bill Clinton
wa no see I I I don't give a [__] he's
he's on Epstein's list 50 times you
don't think the world's paying attention
right now if there's underage girls
that's what's going on hold them
accountable just banging random chicks
and he has an illegitimate child half of
America has that [__] I'm just I'm just
saying though what about you I'm not
just sticking with the underage kid
thing what about the rape allegations oh
she just throw that one away none of my
business okay it's none of your business
because you don't care he's already he's
already been on trial for that yeah but
he Adam he want go you already want to
go relegate 10 1107 guys maybe we should
just turn left into daily Plaza Drive
past the book let spin this positive
I'll do it real quick here's why the
Epstein thing is not going away you I
don't know why you're making this so
much about Clinton let's make this about
Epstein you're like so fixated on
Clinton let's make this about Epstein
and this is why Epstein isn't going away
conspiracy theories JFK who the biggest
of all time Elvis oh people think he's
still alive Tupac All That was
pre-social media all that was pre-
podcast all that was before this
disruption that's going on the reason
that this is never going to go away for
Epstein is
because people like us people that have
podcasts people that have social media
people that have voices people that want
freaking answers are not going to drop
this the Whitney webs of the world are
not going to be silent and this is what
the people want to know about so this is
the reality I like to stay fixated on
what the hell happened with Epstein not
slick Wily but but slick will but out of
all people who was mentioned the most
that's my point is him prince Andrew no
no it's not it's 50 how many times did
they fly there Adam Bill Clinton is all
over the story we just talked about was
Bill Clint so my thing is Adam just
accountability bre heart you're breaking
his heart don't do that it's
accountability said there's no
accountability he was the first
president you ever voted for you said
that I'm still I'm still saying that
it's the truth I was 18 years old so but
anyways uh uh having said that podcast
is over gang for those of you guys that
kept coming back I have to tell you I
have a lot of respect for you I
appreciate you uh thank you uh the good
news is this is going to be cut up in
Clips YouTube just got back to us they
said they're going to send us an email
telling us what's going on we just
checked other channels as well some
podcasts that are nonrelated to politics
to see if they're experiencing it some
of them didn't uh so it seems to be the
Jimmy doors are having it Tim Cass are
having it a few of them are having it
but some of the regular Channel shows
are not experiencing what we just
experienced today we'll investigate a
little bit more to see if there's
anything credibility to it or not aside
from that um have a great weekend we
will do this again next week and again
for those of you guys that are hardcore
hard hardcore viewers of uh the podcast
text the word podcast to
31034 1132 so you can know what we're
going to be doing God knows what's going
to happen in the future but stay close
with texting the word podcast to 31034
11132 have a great weekend take care
bye-bye